reg how are you today I am doing great
Theodore how are you friend well I
trying to understand the postgame press
conference here with Oklahoma City with
Russell Westbrook did did you see the
exchange I did and I think it's worth
noting there is some history between
Barry Trammell and rust that dates back
a couple years I don't know the exact
extent of you know what it is but I have
seen clips of the two of them kind of
going back and forth in postgame and
postgame dialogue look was the question
fair absolutely the question was fair
could it have been delivered a little
bit differently
absolutely but once again once that
happened it was rushed basically
shutting him down in front of his
colleagues in a press conference and you
know let's face it kind of embarrassing
him a little bit and it was very coming
back saying my question wasn't answered
so it's unfortunate because Russ needs
to understand at the end of the day the
power of the Pend will always win and no
matter whatever beef you have it look
I've had my beefs with certain
columnists and writers beat writers you
try to keep it professional because at
the end of the day they always win
because they will always have the last
say because they are really waiting for
that one misstep from you and it will
always happen because Father father time
catches up to all of us and you just got
to learn in your delivery to be a little
bit more respectful
I get where he's coming from I agree
with you Stephen Adams probably could
have handled that question that question
but I like the approach that russ has
taken we're all in this together because
a lot of times people love to kind of
pile on Russ saying and I was one of
them that you know it's a one-man band
he's out there all alone
he's not it's a team game it's always
been a team game and I kind of liked him
coming to the defense of his teammate
what do you think does he stay there
because he's got full autonomy there and
to show now now that's a question does
anybody want to play with him or do you
see him playing someplace else you know
can the Clippers make a deal for him or
does he play for the Lakers can he do
that after he criticized Kevin Durant
for leaving Ike it's an interesting
offseason it feels like for Oklahoma
City well number one I applaud him for
staying just like I don't discount Katie
for living it's a business and you know
the same thing we talked about Boogie
cousin boogie cousins wanted to stay in
Sacramento and at the all-star game next
thing he knows he's being traded you
know to the pelicans
so you know we can't get on KD for
making a business decision and wanting
to play somewhere else we've got to hold
each side accountable management as well
as players but I applaud him for wanting
to stay I think it will be a big
offseason for Sam Presti MLK see because
it's a franchise that's the only show in
town a loyal fan base and you're right
they gave him the keys to the kingdom
the car the the country home the
vacation home they gave them everything
and now they got to start to build
around them they got young talent you
know I love Steven Adams we got Kanter
who's been very disappointing to me in
this season they traded for Victor
Oladipo who hasn't played up to
expectations during the playoffs but
they've got to get some some players
around him Reggie will be he called the
Clippers jazz game for last night with
ISO Joe and he'll get Game five Thunder
Rockets coming up tomorrow night
speaking of the Clippers here are we
starting to inch closer to the end of
Lob City uh well it depends on what goes
on and the rest of this series look
let's start what Blake's done though for
pretty red does he play for the red
purse agrees does he play for the
Clippers again this is how I look at it
right now the Clippers have this the
number one show in town over the Lakers
in
it's never been that case it's always
been a Lakers town but right now until
the Lakers get their footing and magic
gets some players in there right now the
number one draw basketball wise is the
Clippers so if you're mister Ballmer if
you're Doc Rivers we've got these three
guys and we've been successful during
the regular season
I get playoffs and the Clippers will
only be judged by what they do in the
playoffs from going forward from here on
out we've got the number one draw and
Blake is a part of that but can these
guys ever get to the finish line
together and healthy and so far that
hasn't been the case if there's one
person that's happy that all this is
going down is Phil Jackson if Carmelo
Anthony because now you've got trading
options if you're Melo you've got the
Clippers and Blake straight up I think
that works for both teams you're looking
at Indiana because of the sweep you've
got
Paul George in play now you've got Miami
in play you've got Boston in play if
you're Phil Jackson in Carmelo Anthony
so you've got trade options and things
to think about if you're a Knicks fan
but for the Clippers I hope they keep
the band together because they've been
so successful during the regular season
I would love to see them healthy but
that's always the question come playoff
time
wait you would trade Blake Griffin for
Melo straight up know a little bit more
would have to go into it hmm the Knicks
would win on that but I don't know
because Blake has not shown me anything
during the playoffs because he's always
been hurt or he gets hurt yeah I'm
trying to I mean the next would still
find a way to screw it up but you would
think if you got Blake Griffin and you
got rid of Melo that would be a plus for
the Knicks but at the end of the day
remember Carmelo has the ultimate trunk
card and it has no matter what they
throw in there he could always say hmm
how to like it talking to Reggie Miller
NBA on TNT next up he's got the Thunder
in the Rockets tomorrow night if Steve
Kerr can't coach how does that affect
the Golden State Warriors it's a huge
loss because we're talking about you
know when you lose your head
which is great to have you know
associate head coach Mike Browns been
around this game a long time he's
coached some great superstars and LeBron
and obviously Kobe and you know he
understands you know what it takes to
win but Steve Kerr you know it's a lot
like Popovich you know you take pop off
that team it's always see this is when
coaching really matters who's come
playoff you know in the NBA in the
college game it's all about the coaches
the coaches they swing you know the
pendulum in the pro game it's it's the
guys during the regular season but the
coaches that's what takes the you know
the great teams to the next level and
Steve Kerr is one of those coaches and
he knows how to push buttons he
understands how to change schemes that's
that Mike Brown doesn't but Steve Kerr
he knows the temperature of his players
better than anyone I just think it would
be a huge loss I am hoping and praying
it's nothing serious and this is just a
minor setback but just looking at that
press conference yesterday and hearing
him answer questions it doesn't look
good now does it
no no not you know it's leaking you know
spinal fluid leaking and you got
headaches and nausea it's never never
good and for me for them to have
exhausted just about every doctor in the
country and they still can't find out
what the answer is or the you know any
solution first for you know Steve and
his family it has to be frustrating
because you know we did a game maybe a
month and a half two months ago and we
asked them a very question how he's
feeling hey I'm great you know we're
doing yoga I'm feeling much better we
got the team incorporated the thing
that's troubling to me just by
appearances and looking at Steve is the
weight loss I don't like the weight loss
it's stressful enough being a player and
or head coach in the league but when you
can when you keep losing weight it's
never a great time
the Cavs sweeping the Pacers but the
media still found a way to knock the
Cavaliers that they only won those four
games by a combined 16 points what do
you take from the Cavs
the Indian employment well number one
haters are going to hate if you're the
Cavs we did what we were supposed to do
because we get rest in looking at their
next realm series between either
Milwaukee or Toronto they're locked in
at 2-2 so they're going at least six
games so we've get we've got at least a
week off to rest up and practice and try
to shore up especially at the defensive
end to me that's probably been there if
you look at the problems of the Cavs has
been at the defensive end I love what
they're doing at the offensive end they
share the basketball they're scoring at
will but defensively and especially
defensive rebounding that's been the
problem early on but you know people are
going to hate but again at the end of
the day it was a sweep and now they get
rest I will always take rest over rust
because you've got guys that have been
banged up on that team is the chance for
them to kind of you know heal a little
bit of those rules and get ready for
their next round
you know Barkley said a couple of weeks
ago that his top five is cemented that
LeBron can't get into his top five I
think Barclays crazy I think LeBron will
end up probably the second or third best
player in the history of the game can
LeBron is he allowed into the top five
yeah and you and I have had this
conversation many of times and I was
hard to do it I was hard pressed to put
him in there
but you have to and I'm going to make an
even stronger case if the Cavs if the
Cavs find a way to get to the finals and
if the Cavs find a way to beat Golden
State or San Antonio you can make a
strong case it may not be a good case
but you can make a strong case that he
is knocking on the door of the goat oh
I'm not saying he would ever pass him
but you can make a case for that six
straight times to the finals now he
hasn't won all of them but there would
be seven straight times to the finals
and you would certainly assume if they
want that he would be Finals MVP so that
would be four Finals MVP correct but you
can't be the greatest of all time and
somebody's not going
door canyon right I said you could make
a case I'm not saying it's a strong Kate
it's you could make a case but then can
you say he could be the second greatest
player of all time numbers wise he's
going to end up if you just look at the
numbers alone you would have to say that
I'm not saying he is because I will
always side with black Jesus don't get
me wrong gone to the final six times six
Finals MVP period and it's the killer
instinct that MJ had I think LeBrons
more of a pleaser and he wants to get
everyone involved and there's nothing
wrong with that but if you're looking at
the numbers alone you could make a case
and it might it might didn't take that
vacation to baseball what he's gone a
trait well I'll put it to you like this
Nate and we talked about this name all
the guys that he denies Hall of Famers
that he's denying myself Ewing John
Ewing Chuck Charles all the guys that he
denied championships and you might want
to throw in Hakeem Olajuwon if he's not
batting a buck 97 and missing fly balls
in the outfield Hakeem Olajuwon may not
have to and he could have gone 8 for 8
he could have gone 8 for 8 that's why
he'd never do that a double-header
ok and it's not a strong case but I will
always side with that that black hat
black Jesus did you ever get anything
from him signed no ah yes I did hold on
Oh backtrack Michael Jackson moonwalk I
decide you didn't sign yes I'm surprised
that you did that it took everything in
my fiber to ask the ball boy to go down
there and get it yeah it was uh it was
for a charity thing and he asked for one
of yours whatever what Mineta
great if mike says I'll do it if you
give me one of your jokes
but you know what's funny I wonder if
Michael Jordan has anything signed from
anyone like would he ask Muhammad Ali
back when Muhammad Ali was yeah if he
would have asked Muhammad Ali for
something yeah I'm trying to think of
people but nobody in the NBA though it's
not like he's going to say to Larry can
I get a Jersey or you know magic
certainly not I do ask magic maybe for
sure I don't know if Mike would hang up
jerseys of other people not necessarily
to hang up Michael Jordan has an
autograph Jesus picture that's how good
hey so we were say Muhammad Ali was
follow than the only person at the time
MJ would have asked for an autograph
sports autograph yeah yeah oh maybe
tiger no no because he's too much of a
big brother yeah okay
Jack Jack Nicholson Jack Nicklaus hmm
maybe but then if Tiger found out about
it that he I don't know you know let's
well I don't know well he certainly
wasn't asking 31 of India I could I can
guarantee you that
but thank you MJ and thank you for the
charity play but was there anybody
anybody who asked who else asks for your
Jersey in the NBA and I don't mean to
embarrass you because nobody did I don't
think anyone really like yeah no one I
know I have the I have the reg
autographed jersey here we gots right
proudly displayed thank you and I
appreciate the dance and I appreciate
you guys but maybe that's the ultimate
respect that people just didn't like you
that they couldn't like they were so
you're so competitive that they would
have a hard time saying hey would you
give it to me knowing that you might say
no you're such a glutton my business
manager Gail D'Agostino she said look
you have to get this jersey signed by MJ
you don't understand how hard it was for
me to like I wasn't going to have
personally I was like there's no way I'm
going to ask him I saw I had to get the
ball oh no to go down there
with the Jersey and the shoes like NJ
this is for Reggie you know and this was
this is right on the border this is
maybe pre-fight or right after it was
one of the you know that big fight I had
with his right after that or right
before that this happened so it was like
very uncomfortable because we really
weren't on time we were on talking terms
to be my first two years and then just
fifth bumps and handshakes the rest of
the way but it was very uncomfortable
when I did it and Thank You MJ but it
was a very uncomfortable act tomorrow
night on TNT reg will do Game five
Thunder Rockets safe travels great to
visit with you reg talk to you soon
Theodore you are the best and I love my
dad net let's do this Reggie Aloysius
Miller the third NBA on TNT the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience